[Applaudissements]
ils vous inviteront à entrer dans la
danse celle des mots celle des gestes
ils ouvriront le bal à bla bla du
printemps des poètes
il n'y a pas vraiment de difficultés
après c'est plus la découverte de la
matière écrit tu vois là et si
d'imaginer un autre univers qui pourrait
à la fois être complémentaires mais en
même temps si ouvrir de ne pas refermer
le texte sur soi-même en fait pour être
dans la narration constante six danseurs
amateurs participent à cet atelier
depuis le mois de janvier
le fait de le lancer le bal par un petit
un petit ou un grand groupe de danseuses
et danseurs c'est ça va aider les tous
les spectateurs du moment vraiment du
mal à se lancer en piste
je suis très intéressé par tout ce qui
est expression artistique sous toutes
ses formes
et voilà je trouvais ça très beau de
mêlée de formes d'expression donc le
geste et le mot elle les participants
évoluent sur des textes choisis par les
itinéraires poétique
ce 22e printemps des poètes est
consacrée cette année à la francophonie
et c'est de la danse sur des textes dits
par des comédiens véronique ellena
malvoisin et benoît lepecquet et ils
sont ils auront à ouvrir le bal
voilà le bal à bla bla et ensuite à
inviter les gens à entrer dans le bal
pour la suite pour toute la soirée pour
ses danseurs ce week-end était la
dernière préparation
le rendez vous est donné pour le 21 mars
au scarabée de la verrière